Titan
the most majestic of Saturn's many moons
and the most promising for life too
it's got a beautiful view and liquid
Lakes on its surface
the only problem is those Lakes aren't
filled with water
they're filled with liquid methane
your mission is to take a five second
dip in one of them
of course you'd have to land on Titan
first so buckle up for the most epic
adventure of your lifetime
Titan is far even at its closest to
Earth this icy moon is still 1.2 billion
kilometers away from us
you'd be looking at roughly seven years
of travel alone in a spaceship
you'd need lots of provisions and a
super Advanced life support system you
know it would be good if you made it to
Titan and didn't freeze or suffocate
somewhere in the middle of the solar
system
yeah that's not going to happen to you
just sit back and enjoy the ride
seeing Saturn up close is amazing
definitely the most spectacular of all
the ringed planets in the solar system
but hey enough sightseeing it's time to
make your way to your destination
Titan is unique in many ways for one
it's larger than our moon
it's even bigger than Mercury the
smallest planet in our Cosmic
neighborhood it's the only Moon that has
a thick atmosphere
it's also the only one that's covered in
liquid lakes rivers and seas
and sometimes it rains here too
sending on Titan would take you about
two and a half hours and you couldn't
just land anywhere like I say Titan is
covered in Lakes so unless you want it
to dip your entire spacecraft in liquid
methane
you better choose your Landing site
carefully
let's try this again
okay now that you've properly landed on
Titan let's go explore this icy world
this moon of Saturn might look a lot
like Venus but it's not as hellishly hot
Titan is one of the most hospitable
places in the solar system
yeah its gravity is only 14 of Earth's
but it's thicker atmosphere makes it
possible for you to walk there even
without a spacesuit but I wouldn't
recommend that you'd need the spacesuit
to keep you warm
Titan is very far away from the Sun so
it doesn't receive as much warmth as we
do here on Earth
you'd be taking a Brisk stroll at a
chilling minus 180 degrees Celsius
well you wouldn't exactly be strolling
more like bouncing around
yeah thanks to Titan's weaker gravity
you'd feel a lot lighter and could jump
higher and move with less effort
now Titan's atmosphere is mostly
nitrogen very similar to Earth's but you
still couldn't breathe on this Moon
because well that's where the similarity
ends
while 95 of the air here is nitrogen the
remaining five percent is methane
you'd need an oxygen tank to survive
even five seconds on this world
yeah it's not just the lakes that have
methane in them there's plenty of
methane in Titans clouds and sometimes
it even rains methane
but this rain isn't anything like you've
seen on Earth it would be more like rain
in slow motion thanks to Titan's lower
gravity and thick atmosphere on Earth
raindrops fall at about 9 meters per
second but on Titan their speed is only
about 1.6 meters per second
that's six times slower
pretty cool walk in the rain
hit but hey you didn't come here for a
walk in the rain you came to take a dip
in Titan's Lakes
I wouldn't do that if I are you oh
excuse me who's here
hi let's do this what's up everybody I'm
Chase I'm from the year 3050. and for
the last well things are a bit wobbly
where I come from I've been traveling
through space and time a lot
thing is I die a lot like a lot
it's kind of like my special power
it all started when I touched this shiny
alien Cube now I can jump Between Worlds
Dimensions time and when I die I always
come back I'm still trying to figure
that one out I I think it has something
to do with Einstein I don't know
it's pretty cool I jumped on the rings
of distant planets been the guest of
honor at an alien feast and not in a
good way uh and there was that one time
I accidentally started an Interstellar
War suit but now I'm here on Titan to
stop you from doing um
whatever it is you're doing
because he only went once unless you're
me
[Music]
so your mission is to take a swim in one
of these methane pools
uh let me break it down for you
first off this ain't no spa day it's
like diving into a freezer Titan's got
this super chilly vat going on you know
what I mean at these temperatures water
is harder than concrete but methane and
ethane they're like yeah it's cold bro
but like we can still chill in liquid
form and so they gather up at these cool
little pools
okay I knew that too sorry no
interrupting I'm still just getting to
the good part now let's say you're
wearing that fancy space suit good news
you won't freeze instantly into an
[Music]
that suit's gonna flow
if for some wild reason you decided to
take the plunge without the suit well
that's it my friend lights out you see
the intense cold would freeze you down
to your bone you couldn't move a muscle
and then the lack of oxygen would
get jump
but five seconds with the spacesuit on
finally survive probably Let's test it
okay
[Music]
ah seems like someone's face to can't
withstand the cold someone needs an
upgrade
it's so refreshing out here I think I'll
just stay another five seconds just to
really enjoy it
[Music]
uh Chase ah don't worry these Sparks are
supposed to happen oh it's like a
stabbing burning feeling
hey
[Music]
it appears that the cold temperature
cracked his suit and methane reacted
with the oxygen tank inside it
he should have read about this in the
mission brief well just leave them here
I guess
anyway the mission is a success the only
thing left is to figure out how to get
home
okay well maybe instead of returning to
Earth we could set up shop on Titan
but that sounds like a story
or another
what if